on va l'aborder merzouki qui s'est
exprimé hier soir avec beaucoup de
mesure finalement ramené charrier
bonjour il va de nouveau prendre la
parole il sera cette fois le format sera
un peu différent il sera cette fois
interrogé par la presse ce sera le
format de conférence de presse il va on
imagine être titillé pouces et danser
dans ses retranchements qu'est ce qui
peut bien l'annoncé d'hier aujourd'hui à
sont payés aux ukrainiens alors la
difficulté pour le président ukrainien
pour le président souligne ski c'est de
s'inscrire à la fois dans une parole
ukrainienne est à la fois dans une
parole écoutée par les occidentaux parce
que vous l'avez entendu finalement la
position des occidentaux elle n'est pas
la même pour tout le monde il y a un axe
qui est très américain britannique et
qui lui craint réellement une menace qui
est une menace russe cet axe là le
président céline ce qui a beaucoup
discuté avec eux c'est cet axe là en
quelque sorte qu'ils avaient ramené
avoir une capacité à intégrer l'otan à
aller dans le cadre de l'union
européenne ensuite il ya un autre axe
qui a parlé avec lui qui est un axe plus
européen plus français plus allemand qui
effectivement dans le processus de minsk
et qui en clair lui disait n'allait pas
trop titiller la fda d'ymir poutine
n'allait pas demander trop est respectée
justement pourquoi on évite d'avoir
quelque chose qui s'aggrave de cette
manière là et puis ensuite il ya la
position ukrainienne j'allais dire plus
classique qui est de savoir
effectivement que on a toujours la
russie qui joue ce jeu là avec ce pays
et qui est ne les nerfs vont pas non
plus clairement aujourd'hui henning ce
qui est coincé parce que il a une partie
de son pays qui a été amputée c'est un
crime et c'est certainement le pays dans
lequel c'est plus difficile à comprendre
parce qu'ils sont directement concernés
aujourd'hui on lui parle effectivement
de ces pays qui sont ces essais
république qui sont dans l'est qui sont
pro russes qui n'ont jamais été
favorables à lui donc c'est pas celle là
auquel il va faire le plus attention
mais en même temps s'il a une rupture de
son pays ça ça veut dire quelque chose
et c'est pour ça qu'il a dit il fallait
garder les frontières du pays donc on va
maintenant voir comment ce qui va le
formaliser